well the Los Angeles school district is
one of the biggest in the country the
district is now instructing teachers to
educate children starting in
kindergarten to experiment with
non-binary pronouns just to kind of
destroy human civilization and throw it
all into chaos and confusion that's
actually happening by the way why is a
school talking to your kindergartners
about sex shouldn't they be in prison
for doing that yes they should be Chris
Ruffo has proved this is going on he's
obtained several documents from The
District's Equity Department he joins us
tonight Chris thanks so much for coming
on tell us what exactly is going on here
if you would
so what's happening is that public
school bureaucrats across the country in
this case in Los Angeles have taken the
principles of academic queer Theory and
then turned them into a K-12 pedagogy
they're training kids as young as
kindergarten to experiment with sexual
identities such as transgender queer
pansexual gender fluid two-spirit all of
these really crazy and synthetic uh
constructions that were we once thought
were relegated to Academia they've now
been mainlined into Elementary School
classrooms all over the school district
in Los Angeles
I really can and I mean this sincerely
I'm confused if I find your
kindergartner in the park and start
talking to her about her sex life you
have a moral right to punch me out and
call the cops
why in the world are we allowing
teachers to do the same thing
well I think a large part of the reason
is because of this illusion of authority
and so the two prominent domains where
these ideas are being transmitted are
education and the medical profession and
uh you know For Better or Worse
historically these have been very
trusted so people listen to teachers
they listen to doctors but I think this
is starting to change because this is
getting frankly out of control and one
thing that is really important to know
that actually school districts like Los
Angeles have adopted an explicit policy
that teachers can facilitate your
child's gender or sexual transition and
the default policy is that they keep it
secret from parents so they know that
they're doing something that parents
would object to I have the documents
that prove exactly what they're doing
and they're trying to keep it a secret
I mean up until recently the rule was
you troll my minor children about their
sex life and you're gonna get hurt and I
think that should be the rule still I
think this is that it's that threatening
I appreciate all you've done
to bring this to like Chris Ruffo thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight